In this lesson, you'll create a menu
app, using the Flask framework.
I will start by showing you the basic
components of a Flask application,
with a simple hello world program,
which you will then create on your own.
Then we will connect to our database via
SQL Alchemy to view all of the items in
each restaurant menu.
Next, you will learn about templates,
and
how they allow you to write HTML code,
separately from Python code.
Keeping your application more organized.
After that,
I will introduce a special function
in Flask called url_for, which builds
the URLs that you will use to navigate
through your new Flask application.
We will then create forms to
capture data from users, and
use message flashing to notify the user
each time they successfully change
information in the database.
I will discuss a way to use
flash to add the option to
send JSON messages instead of HTML.
And finally, take some time to
style our app with some CSS.